The jogan
Experience waras rather is there any of
these dagistan guys that look exactly
like M I was like maff fighting already
they like to have a beard man it's
racist man I'm just saying they look
exactly like it's such an interesting
look the beard with no mustache if I was
Hamza and my had that big cut on my lip
I might want to get like a mustache or
scary like the red drag Abraham Lincoln
spent 10 years in doown showing him you
know he wrestled AB he's get him look at
his face he's trying to hold us off he
almost me he almost had me he me I'm
telling you the truth he he he was aest
it was a foreign exchange dude he kind
of bro he just had that twinkle that
twinkle of joke in your eye that I can
recognize did you know Abraham Lincoln
used to wrestle he used to be a badass
wrestle 6 he was legit AB was all over
the Middle East and he wrestled wrestled
was dicks in his but real [__] what yeah
Abe Lincoln had a side piece dude look
it was his security guard and they
[__] really this isn't some bring it
up I'm going to ask you I'm going to ask
you to respect your country I think
there's probably some long camping trips
back there and a lot of guys [__] I'm
tell you
look was not banging guys cold winners
cold winners Lincoln was an amazing
wrestler he influenced a lot of people
all over the world in wrestling before
he was a president this is hey and did
they say his voice was really high he's
speaking that up he didn't travel nobody
traveled back there he's imagine if you
had that picture right there that was
taken uh in Russia an hour south of
Moscow an hour do you have any idea how
long it would take to get to Russia from
[__]
Pennsylvania wrestling
match no no for your information the
boat the ferry from from the east coast
to to England
that's 30 days so that's 30 days and
then you take a wagon to
[Music]
[__] training on the boat four months
by he's just eating beef jerky training
on the boat dude he'll be in Kazakhstan
in no time right wagon you got to bring
your they traveled in blimps back then
that's a the history that's been erased
people were traveling all over the world
no no now I'm like being real you want
get
oh no no they had blimps in the 1800s
they were traveling all over Ed they
definitely did when they built the
Empire State Building telling you
Coleman Hughes was showing us that uh
the other day when Coleman was here he
explained that the Empire State Building
they made it so high cuz they were going
to park blimps at the top of dude that's
what they did back then yeah but they
didn't do it they tried to do it but too
windy they just used as an excuse to
make the tallest building to say we have
to make it this tall we're going to park
blimps and you remember that remember
that you know that lead Zeppelin cover
of the of the Zeppelin blimp crashing
that was to uh just erase blimps from
history we don't want blimps they're too
they're too dangerous Ze was on board
with this the CIA got a hold of Ze you
don't think you don't think the CIA
created the music business well no you
guys you don't know about this but I
think musicians created the mus when you
find out the
CIA control they created the Hipp
movement they created it they created
the record scene the music industry no
who was Jim Morrison's dad tell him Joe
knows this J's dad did what he was like
a CIA guy yeah he orchestrated the Gulf
of tonan false FL do you know that B did
you know you ever heard him sing that's
why he rebelled from no wonder I like
dude I never like the doors I was like
when I growing up I'm like the doors
what this is the end is a good song This
is the end but other than that Break On
Through To The Other Side take oh my God
I hate that [__] put it on oh my
God you can on YouTube oh I hated that
[__] can we play it on
YouTube like dude I hat that flying knee
was amazing
Savage what was the other one what was
other the oh my God horrible wow Eddie
dude even though never wanted he never
wanted to
be there was no aspirations to be a
rockar singer all of a sudden he just
became one
a Edie Eddie he was very talented the
doors were
talented you there's a book called you
you like books right there's a book
called weird scenes on Laurel Canyon I
have the book I'll give it to you Monday
D weird scenes on loyal I'm gonna give
Dave mown holy [__] they orchestrated
all that [__] when you look at the other
bands that were living in Laurel Canyon
at the time it's nuts it was all CIA and
you know Lookout Mountain Laboratories
that was a a a top secret Air Force
intelligence they you know who owns that
now Jared Leto Jared Leto yes who wrote
the songs were musicians what do you
mean you wonder why you think jarald let
I don't know Jared I don't know going
listen 30 Seconds to Mars they got a
good song they got a song called
Echelon that's a good song weird scenes
I don't know that guy lives in in
Lookout Mountain laboratory he bought it
Eddie he he doesn't age either Ed when
Eddie's getting into this he starts
doing this like like you get the hands
I'm on this wave with Eddie though dud
good dude I don't want to believe it I
don't want to believe that that Jared
Leto is not a [__] government agent
I'm not saying but he lives in
look he bought bought it too bro it's
dope it's a giant former [__]
government
building what I will on a giant piece of
property in Hollywood Hills jar letto
Jared Leto is the only dude in the
history of the world to be to be a a
legit Arena filling rock star songwriter
and an A-list actor no other guy has
done
that a very nice guy I hung out with him
went to dinner with him me him Theo
and I love him he's a great guy he's a
really nice guy the song Echelon back
back uh back in the day I love that song
so much I drove to Vegas for a a spe
specific reason I don't want to talk to
about it but I go to Vegas suspect back
in the day back in the day I go to
Vegas it was a girl no it was a girl I
was like back when I Wasing and I listen
to I listen to Echelon on repeat for
five hours all the way to Vegas oh he's
one of my favorite people I love that
song it is amazing he live Lookout
Mountain laboratory Edie I would have
[__] bought that place if I found out
it was available I would have bought it
how do we know how do know I would
bought it and turned that [__]
into like giant Playhouse I don't know
dog it's bomb proof too wouldn't your
dad
know he my dad your dad my dad into this
that flying knee oh [__] look at that
flying knee we missed it look at look at
this
[__] here it comes Bo did you know Frank
zapp's dad was uh a deep into um
biological chemical warfare type [__]
yeah but see a lot of those young kids
that have dads like that the dads are
never home that's how they become rock
stars not because their dad [__]
schooled them and brought them through
the CIA to make them manipulate the
population they're rebelling against
their dad the dad's never home if your
dad is in the CIA you're [__] dud you
got to you got to you got to listen to
the we scenes in in Laurel Canyon it's
going to blow fck I just got it just
it's so good they needed that was the
the theory is in the' 60s most of the
anti Vietnam uh protesters were were
were were like college professors and Le
like they were respectable people uh
going against the Vietnam war that
guy that guy's like why is don't talk
about this there's
B oh that guy was my please please keep
listen you know what when I when I get
when I'm when I'm doing fight companion
and I get into some deep [__] and you
guys cut me off like you always do you
know what you got to put your headphones
you know what I think I go I go thank
God they cut me off now I don't have to
worry about someone killing me I love it
when you guys cut me off you know what I
don't need to get into that put the
headphones on so we can all coordinate
and not not talk over each other I hate
headphones